[Music]  absolutely Minister my knees are shaking  a little bit because I wasn't expecting  us  I mean it's a very sacred spot and I  mean you feel that sacredness when you  go into the building and especially into  the shrine itself you you see the  pilgrims who are in ecstasy as they go  in and they're seeing something that  they believed in all their life and and  that feeling no specialness it just  permeates the whole building  the slab of marble on the top was  believed to be of Jesus's to has just  been removed and archaeologists are now  analyzing what's underneath it a big can  they see at the bottom where the rock  goes back to and dated back to the time  of when Jesus would potentially have  been around  [Music]  our ground penetrating radar would not  work  like type amazed that's the goal for  this week to say this isn't this is the  GPS point that was first found in the  3rd century AD I mean that's the weight  of history in your hands  [Music]  [Music]